they keep bludgeoning us over the head
with this nonsense and for years nobody
did anything and then came along Florida
man yeah Ron DeSantis was like I've had
just about enough of your gay beer and
your gay cards and your gay cartoons
and we're gonna do something about it uh
you know what he's doing well yesterday
he officially signed the signed it it
had been a long time coming but they're
closing up the legislative session here
in Florida so he's signing a whole bunch
of stuff right now he officially
signed the bill which will ban trans
surgeries on minors which is a major
major win and hopefully this will be
exported throughout the entire country
obviously Cali isn't going to do it New
York's not going to do it et cetera et
cetera but hopefully as many states as
possible we'll see hey let's not Chop
genitals off kids that's a winning thing
let's go ahead and do it here's DeSantis
the SB 254 this will permanent Outlaw
the mutilation of minors it will Outlaw
the surgical procedures and experimental
puberty blockers for minors it will also
require any adults receiving these
surgeries to be informed about the
irreversible nature and about the
dangers of the procedures it will give
Florida courts temporary jurisdiction to
intervene and halt procedures for
out-of-state children you have actually
some states
in this country that want to be a Haven
for these types of procedures and even
welcome minors without their parents
consent into some of their jurisdiction
we're obviously doing the opposite here
and I think this is this provision is
important this is going to create a way
to recover damages for injury or death
resulting from mutilating surgeries or
these experimental puberty blockers that
are given to a minor because what
happens they go through this then they
get older and this is a huge problem
they should be able to sue the physician
who hurt them and they're now going to
be able to with this law yeah everything
he said there it's true it's reality
based we all know it's right you should
not be giving these kids these puberty
blockers kids that are having all sorts
of confusions and they might have gender
dysphoria or whatever it might be some
of them will grow up let's just say to
be gay people some of them will grow up
to be straight some of them have all
sorts of other issues but we Don don't
let 12 year olds get tattoos without
parents permission but for some reason
you're allowed to chop their boobs off
we're not going to force anyone to use
any of these ridiculous pronouns
DeSantis also signed something on that
front Bill make sure that Florida
students and teachers will never be
forced to declare pronouns in school or
be forced to use pronouns not based on
biological sex we never did this through
all of human history until like what two
weeks ago now this is something they're
having third graders declare pronouns
we're not doing the pronoun Olympics in
Florida it's not happening here and so
just to be clear guys none of this is
based in hate or bigotry or anything
else I know you know that but when
you're communicating some of this to
your friends well that means he hates
gay people he hates trans people no he
is defending kids and not offering
endless confusion
[Music]
thank you